win a tattoo shop that's right a las
vegas man went plans to raffle his
business
right near the strip 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond shows
us the reason for the contest and the
big business gamble
if you've ever dreamed of owning your
own tattoo parlor well now here's your
chance one lucky person has the
opportunity to win
black omen tattoo here on the corner of
flamingo and paradise
the shop's all set up with like all the
supplies
set up and ready for business all it
needs a new owner
whoever wins this i want them to have it
caleb cashew wants to raffle his tattoo
shop
next year we've been doing business for
four years you know so
all they got to do is walk in and turn
on the open side
he's rolling the dice on enough people
wanting to participate in the contest
to help him raise enough money to walk
away a decision
not based on the coveted situation but
choosing to move closer to family on the
east coast
in october my wife and i had our first
baby
family's always been really important to
us he also wants to help a potential
entrepreneur avoid the startup hassles
i want to pass the torch i want to gift
this to someone i want to change their
life the contest works like this
anyone around the country can buy an
artwork print starting at 45 dollars
each piece includes a golden ticket
eligible for the raffle
which cashew says he will live stream no
matter what you're getting something for
your money
a risk reward investment and opportunity
vegas loves to gamble so
it's a gamble for me too so i'm taking
that chance
the contest is scheduled for july 21st
of next year but if cashy sells 2021
prints before that date
he'll move up the raffle reporting in
las vegas kristin drummond 8 news now